pakistan has had a tumultuous weekend
after its legislature ousted imran khan
from office following a vote of no
confidence given the country's political
polarization and the power of the
military there were concerns any impasse
would lead to further instability
[Applause]
the high drama continued on monday in
the national assembly as it was set to
elect a new prime minister ahead of that
vote khan's party staged a walkout
boycotting the election with pakistan
deep in political crisis the country's
new leader shabaz sharif faces the same
challenges khan did including a
dysfunctional economy
joining us is journalist hajira maryam
in islamabad
can you tell us more about what happened
in parliament today in pakistan's new
prime minister
yeah so basically today you know
the session was carried out in order to
vote for the new prime minister of
pakistan's pakistan the hurricane
party the members they resign and mass
and then a boat was carried out and now
shahbaz sharif he is elected as the
prime minister of pakistan the 23rd
prime minister of pakistan now mr
shabbat sharif you know he is also part
of the wealthy sharif clan he is brother
of the former prime minister of pakistan
mr navashiri from the pakistan muslim
noon party and even though he is not
well known internationally in the
domestic sphere he is a very famous uh
politician and an administrator he was
the former chief minister of punjab and
you know because of his administrative
capabilities like he was able to
carry out mega funding mega-projects you
know in order for the development of the
province and uh unlike his brother nawaz
sharif mr shabbat sharif is known to
have a very amicable relationship with
the country's
military yeah and that's really
important now before we talk more about
the future i i want to back up a bit you
were covering protests this weekend how
were people feeling and what were they
telling you
uh i mean i myself yes just yesterday
you know i was in
uh at zero point in islamabad and i
myself i was pretty overwhelmed by
looking at the numbers the people out
there on the streets are probably in
thousands or probably half a million of
people like who i like who i was able to
interview and talk to them and it was
pretty interesting because the first
time is it's probably one of the first
few times when such a big
massive mass mobilization is taking
place across major cities across
pakistan and a few slogans that they
have been chanting people were chanting
were
again it was based on the sentiment of
anti-americanism but an interesting turn
of events is also they were you know
standing against the army uh they were
you know not they were completely in
support of iran
so what's your assessment on this
political outcome uh did the rule of law
and uh democracy prevail you talked
about the importance of the military in
all of this
yeah i mean since pakistan's inception
you know since 1947
no pakistani prime minister has ever
served their full time to date and imran
khan also uh unfortunately joined the
fate of his pre-predecessors
you know it's uh since 2018 and it is my
own personal observation since 2018
elections i think military is now
understanding that you know they cannot
really govern like right at the
forefront instead what they do they
maintain like these uh you know they get
these puppet regimes in order to you
know uh
kind of uh hold on to their power and
even though in the at this period of
time you know pakistan has been
embroiled with
in weeks of political instability in a
week's time you know the country had a
prime minister then the country did not
have a prime minister the country had a
prime minister again and then he was
ousted in a no-confidence vote
hajira miriam thank you so much for your
time